why are we here
how is it that matter exists
was there ever a moment in cosmic
history
before which no matter existed and after
which matter such as the type of matter
we're made up of did exist that's a
fundamental question related to
symmetries
in our closest held notions
of particle physics
and relativity
today we explore a fascinating new
experimental result looking for small
deviations departures from perfect
symmetry observed at everybody's
favorite particle collider the
relativistic heavy ion collider or rick
at brookhaven national laboratory
on long island where i was born 50 years
ago come and explore with me today on
into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from
magic what tipped the balance of our
universe towards matter and less towards
anti-matter if the symmetry were perfect
we wouldn't be here because all of
matter would have annihilated with all
the anti-matter in the early universe
leaving nothing behind but a bath of
cold pitiless photons
that would be indifferent to our
existence
researchers at rick decided to probe the
existence of departures from perfect
symmetry in magnetic fields and they did
so using what are called isobars
isobars are atoms that have the same
mass the same atomic number but have
different numbers of protons when these
atoms are stripped of electrons they
become ions and the ions will be
stronger and produce stronger electric
and magnetic fields the more protons
they have than if they have fewer
protons
in this case physicists collided two
different ions two different isobaric
ions so an isobar is an ion that has the
same total mass as another ion but
different numbers of protons so in this
case they collided zirconium which has
an atomic mass of 96 with
also containing 40 protons in its
nucleus with ruthenium 96 which has 96
as its atomic mass but an extra four
protons so it has higher charge which
could lead to higher magnetic fields as
well as higher electric fields so in
such a case the ruthenium should
generate a stronger magnetic field when
it's cruising through the relativistic
heavy iron collider at speeds
approaching the speed of light
and in that case they thought these
scientists operating at rick thought
that the magnetic field increase would
result in a greater separation of
charged particles emerging from
collisions than those seen in zirconium
zirconium collisions physicists in the
star collaboration which is using the
relativistic heavy ion collider rick
at brookhaven national laboratory
presented long-awaited results just
recently in this year which
unfortunately didn't allow us to reveal
the fundamental
violation of magnetism from such
isobaric properties but the experiment
is an important stake in the ground
which will eventually allow us to probe
deeper and deeper into the chiral
anomalies known as chiral and magnetic
field effects in both subatomic
particles and later as we'll explore on
this channel in the cosmos at large
looking for violations of lorenz
invariants using cmb photons in upcoming
experiments like the simon's observatory
that we've talked about in previous
videos as you know i believe there's a
wealth of interesting and fascinating
videos out there on the internet from my
colleagues like sean carroll hopefully
we'll have you back when these results
are confirmed if not sooner i'll be too
important i won't come on your podcast
anymore it's being a hossenfelder i
really wish that the theorist you know
the string theorists and quantum gravity
people and what have you would actually
make a prediction for an experiment
before they make the experiment and
other great theoretical minds and i feel
like it's part of my job maybe my niche
if you will to provide information about
experiments both particle physics
experiments and cosmological experiments
such as the one i'm privileged to be a
part of called the simon's observatory
and the simon's array in the atacama
desert of chile
so in doing so i hope to give you all
out there information about what it
means to be a successful experiment just
because this result didn't actually come
up with a final definitive answer
proving or disproving the existence of
chiral magnetic field effects it was
still a success
and it is a success and it is a
constraint that we can now know about
our universe that can illuminate where
to go next
and where to look forward to
now not all experiments succeed but just
because a result comes out with what's
called an upper limit in other words it
didn't produce a definitive signal
leading researchers to support the claim
of a chiral magnetic field effect i
can't prove this it is still a success
because it provides new information
useful clues about where to look next in
other pieces of data from rick or other
particle accelerators and also from the
larger cosmic laboratory that we
cosmologists are attempting to use with
projects in the cosmic microwave
background field experiments and the
researchers in star say this null result
or this upper limit doesn't close the
door on anything it actually allows them
to go deeper and provide new insight now
let's see where this story starts it
actually began over 20 years ago in the
year 2000
and actually one could say it might even
go back to the very beginning of time
itself so these researchers use what are
called off-center collisions where gold
ions were moving very close and the
asymmetric separation of charged
particles produced interesting magnetic
field phenomena as shown in this
illustration here
they look for what would could be
potentially perceived as a broken
symmetry within this hot plasmatic
material that could be indicative of a
chiral magnetic field
and since that time in 2000 they
collected a huge ton of ion data and at
higher and higher energies they were
effectively reproducing the phenomena
that were present in the first fraction
of a second after the big bang namely
what's known as a quark gluon plasma or
qgp for short
and this is an almost simulacrum of what
the universe was like in its earliest
moments when quarks and gluons coalesce
to form the protons and neutrons that
make up ordinary matter that we see in
the universe and that we're made up of
results from the so-called off-center
collisions at rick revealed an
asymmetric separation of the charged
particles that emerged from the
collisions
in each event these charged particles
that were emerging went along the
magnetic field lines generated by the
swirling mass of these colliding
plasmatic ions when the negatively
charged particles came out in the
opposite directions they viewed that as
a hint
pointing to perhaps a broken symmetry so
by probing these broken symmetries
physicists believe they could offer
clues into some of the biggest mysteries
in all of science such as what prevailed
in the most early moments in our
universe if the big bang produced an
excess of matter over antimatter it
would make sense but we have no way to
understand how did that fundamental
asymmetry get there and we actually know
the asymmetry is minute
at the one part per billion level in
other words for every billion protons
there's one billion minus one
antiprotons in the early universe
leaving us with two billion photons from
the annihilation and just one proton one
particle of normal matter left over
so nuclear physicists believe that the
separation asymmetry could be caused by
a chiral property of the magnetic field
leading to an excess of left or right
handedness of the emitted particle
depending on whether or not that
particle is spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise relative to its
direction of motion
and as they believe that this could take
place in the quark gluon plasma and if
this took place in the quark gluon
plasma at rick there's a notion that you
could have an asymmetry in the earliest
moments of the universe when the whole
universe was a particle accelerator
so these chirally imbalanced bubbles
within the magnetic field produced would
lead to a separation of these electric
charges which could be probed
and this understanding the chiral
magnetic field effect could be real and
yet the researchers at rick may not have
enough energy or they may not have had
enough exposure of crashing these ions
together to trigger an event that could
be measurable so these researchers are
very careful they actually underwent
five independent
analyses uh and separated into five
different groups that provide formed
what was known as a blind analysis in
other words the physicist didn't cover
their eyes instead they looked into the
data and divided up in a way that would
eliminate a signal if it was real until
the last moment when they were convinced
they understood the properties of the
experiment perfectly well
so when they saw the swirling off-center
collision data that generates the
chiro-magnetic field they wondered if
there was a way to actually reveal it
and predict it in greater detail for
upcoming experiments so the key to
getting a larger and larger chiral
signal is to have the center of mass to
have this off-center collisions be
greater and at higher energies and they
could do so by measuring the properties
of isobars of ions with the same mass
but different protonic number they
controlled everything they could do
including switching back and forth
between the two types of collisions
sometimes they had to do it in the very
same day and this is a tour de force of
experimental technology at brookhaven
and it's probably possible almost
nowhere else on earth so it's really a
fundamental remarkable
discovery and collaboration working
incredibly hard over years to produce an
exquisitely precise result happens not
to prove or disprove the existence of
chiral magnetic fields however it does
make an important step forward in our
understanding of the quark gluon plasma
that physicists believe prevailed at the
earliest moments in the universe so as
an experimentalist i was fascinated by
the links that these team members went
in their own field as different as
possible from cosmology that i traffic
in as as it could be a quark to the
cosmos they underwent a blinding
analysis that eliminates the possibility
of confirmation bias and preventing
themselves from fooling themselves as
richard feynman says the first principle
is to not fool yourself and the second
thing to note is you're the biggest fool
there is so they had to be very careful
they covered up the results into the
last moment they controlled things as
well as they could and anything beyond
their control such as the shape of the
colliding ions the emission that came
out that could have affected the results
they tried to make as insensitive as
possible so they designed a clean
experiment with low background and high
precision and they looked for these
ultra subtle effects
so a physicist by the name of karziv who
first predicted the existence of the
chiral magnetic field effect in 2004
who's been looking for it ever since
said he would not be disappointed if the
rick signal failed to appear
and actually the article that i'm
quoting from actually appeared before he
knew what the result was so he wasn't
biased the experimentalists have a lot
to look forward to because they say that
the magnitude of this chiral magnetic
field effect is larger at smaller
collision energies meaning you don't
need a more massive particle accelerator
so you can observe this effect perhaps
more precisely by analyzing data from
lower energy collisions at rick for it
to be observed you need the magnetic
field and when the collision energy is
too high the nuclei pass through each
other so quickly that they fail to feel
the magnetic field forces that's tough
to say but it's important to note that
they could actually look at larger
charge separation requiring lower energy
not higher energy so the isobar run
where they use similar masses but
different number of protons will provide
new data to look for
a higher signal to background ratio
results experimentalists like and
theorists like karziv now know the
direction that they have to pursue
namely they can look for isobaric
collisions and that may help us
understand what the universe was like
during this ultra early
epoch and its evolution namely when the
whole universe was a pork plasma soup
and some of these may hint at strategies
that we can also look for using
cosmological data that i'll be talking
about in a future video when we discuss
the measurement of so-called primordial
magnetic fields
[Music]
if you like this video i know that
you'll like my discussion with dan
hooper about the g minus two results so
excitingly brought to our attention
earlier this year click here for those
results
[Music]
you